[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa por las pantallas
de france 24 y hoy los saludamos desde
la playa de parís que cada verano se
instala en el río sena y en el canal de
luz
[Música]
o no
tras dos años de kobe al fin llegaron
las vacaciones y muchos franceses ya han
partido sin embargo el alza de los
precios de los combustibles y la alta
inflación están obligando a adaptar los
planes como un balde de agua fría así ha
caído la inflación en el presupuesto de
verano de los franceses muchos quieren
reducir gastos como estos en la costa
azul
vamos a llevar así le doy algunos gustos
a mi hija como un helado o un chocolate
pero no iremos a restaurantes imposibles
temo una papita aquí la vamos en lugar
de ir a un hotel porque es más caro pero
estemos en gastar menos esa es la meta
de un 64% de los franceses estas
vacaciones esperan dejarse en 1641 euros
en promedio contra mil 765 en el 2019
pero vacaciones más baratas son también
vacaciones más cerca
en comparación con el año pasado cuando
teníamos gente de parís o de un poco más
al norte de la capital
[Música]
este año se trata especialmente de
personas de nuestra región para que el
partir cerca es la opción también de
esta familia del departamento de lesson
en el sur de parís suelen vacacionar en
un camping cerca de burdeos pero este
año no será posible
a nivel de gasolina y peajes el camping
no sale muy caro y los precios de
alquiler han aumentado enormemente
no podemos permitirnos gastar tanto el
curso no nos confundan en su lugar han
elegido el departamento de la vende más
al norte donde encontraron una casa más
pequeña y económica un ahorro de dos mil
euros según sus cálculos
después de dos años de vacas flacas los
empresarios del turismo cantan victoria
el sector está en una amplia
recuperación sin embargo eso hace temer
sobre todo a los administradores de
sitios naturales de que está alta
frecuentación los ponga en peligro
hace algunos años la playa de isla
virgen en bretaña llevaba una vida
pacífica lejos de los turistas pero eso
hasta que en el 2014 la organización
europea en vez de extensión la pusiera
en el puesto número 7 del ranking de las
playas más bonitas de europa poco
después el británico the guardian fue
más lejos y calificó a esta parte del
litoral entre las más bellas del planeta
desde entonces la playa ha sido invadida
por blogueros dispuestos a hacer
cualquier cosa para obtener la foto
perfecta
pero hay un problema el acantilado es
inestable el sitio está empezando a
desmoronarse
entre 2011 y hoy triplicamos la
frecuencia de visitantes básicamente
pasamos de 20.000 a 65.000 personas por
año en este sendero esto sin contar a
las personas que vienen a descubrir el
sitio de la isla virgen pero esta playa
no es la única víctima de su éxito en el
otro extremo de francia la cala de zombi
ahora es monitoreada por la policía
una primicia de marsella la prevención
pasa también por la concienciación
medioambiental ya que estamos en el
corazón del parque natural de las
palancas y está prohibido fumar y
consumir alcohol las palancas acogen
miles de visitantes cada verano este
hacinamiento genera erosión del suelo en
algunas partes para protegerlo el
municipio ha limitado el acceso en dos
sitios particularmente frágiles las
calas de su heaton y pierre ahora es
necesario reservar un lugar en internet
el aforo máximo es de 400 personas al
día
y si algunos sitios se están
restringiendo el acceso a las turistas
otros hacen lo imposible por atraerlos
es el caso de un pueblo en alsacia donde
lo dejaron todo para ser incluidos en la
lista de los pueblos más bellos de
estancia
en el corazón de las viñas en alsacia
wehrheim con sus calles empedradas
murallas medievales y casas con
entramados de madera es una joya aún
desconocida del gran público esta mañana
un particular visitante recorre sus
calles
pascal bernard de la asociación que
designa a los pueblos más bellos de
francia una visita decisiva para obtener
la codiciada etiqueta rosales poza
polares de textos y dos herramientas son
esenciales las cámaras y un plano para
poder orientarte cuando vas a explorar
todo un pueblo
ok había un reloj solar me lo perdí y de
más tarde primer paso visita guiada por
el pueblo
junto a la alcaldesa pascal de anna debe
comprobar si wehrheim cumple con los 27
criterios establecidos por su asociación
concretamente miramos todo miramos el
tratamiento de los espacios públicos la
vegetación el tratamiento de los
edificios privados y si los servicios
van bajo tierra
pascal bernard es detallista hay poco de
que preocuparse en términos de
patrimonio ver gente tiene mucho que
envidiar murallas del siglo 15 e incluso
una iglesia románica donde hacen nido
unas cigüeñas símbolo del sacyl
estamos mirando todo lo que va bien pero
también estamos mirando los puntos de
mejora aquí todavía hay fachadas que
lamentablemente fueron un poco
maltratadas hace varias décadas así que
cuando haya trabajos por hacer debe
asegurarse de que las rehabilitaciones
sean según las normas artísticas la
alcaldesa está segura debería obtener
esta etiqueta sin dificultad
siempre que pague la cuota anual de casi
cinco mil euros para ser parte de la
asociación
una inversión rentable a sus ojos la
etiqueta atrae a muchos turistas y apoya
la economía local
esta tienda de abarrotes por ejemplo
reabrió hace menos de un año y realmente
sus negocios que me gustaría apoyar
porque es importante para la gente del
pueblo
el reto es económico pero también
simbólico para los habitantes de bergen
muy apegados a su pueblo como vemos que
se reúne con sus amigos cada tarde bajo
este estilo de 1300
estamos enamorados de este pueblo todo
de los amigos es un pueblo maravilloso
nacimos allí hasta la fecha cerca de 200
pueblos han obtenido el preciado sello
pero nada es definitivo la asociación
quiere ser exigente y comprueba cada
seis años que los pueblos seleccionados
se mantienen a la altura de sus
criterios
después de nuestra visita wehrheim fue
elegido uno de los pueblos más bellos de
francia e incluso pueblo preferido de
los franceses
y si 33 millones de franceses van a
impartir otros 33 se van a quedar en
casa este verano normal 24 de cada 10
franceses no parte de viaje durante sus
vacaciones de verano y eso está
vinculado en la mayoría de las veces al
nivel económico del grupo familiar
para ellos en la periférica comuna de
pantano las siete fértil es una
alternativa
[Música]
por ejemplo aquí el en tu eres
coordinadora del aceite fértil que es la
a-7 thirteen y cuáles son sus valores
sin saber es un espacio comunitario que
está instalado en una antigua estación
de trenes de carga de la empresa de
ferrocarriles francesa que queda en
parte un barrio prioritario de la
periferia de parís en natpe hay en una
nueva elección de culpen de c's de
nuestra apuesta y los valores que nos
mueven son experimentar la ciudad del
mañana es decir buscar soluciones para
proteger la biodiversidad para hacer
accesible el máximo de actividades
lúdicas y pedagógicas hacemos todo lo
posible para acoger a todos aquellos que
se esfuerzan por que haya menos pobreza
más educación accesible y más
iniciativas empresariales femeninas esos
son algunos ejemplos de lo que
intentamos experimentar desde 2018 que
lo que encontramos en este lugar que era
una antigua estación de trenes que
encontramos en la cita y fértil
donde teníamos la mitad de las
actividades en exteriores y la mitad del
interior tenemos una huerta tenemos
panales de abejas para la apicultura
tenemos un invernadero espacios de
deporte canchas con redes deportivas son
espacios abiertos pero también cerrados
como una biblioteca una biblioteca de
semillas una librería solidaria un
restaurante varios bares e incluso las
cubas para fermentar la cerveza que
bebemos aquí mismo tenemos también
varios espacios de trabajo compartidos
muy calmados donde podemos venir un día
una semana o varios meses todo eso es lo
que podemos encontrar elena la a-7
fértil se encuentra como tú decías en un
barrio prioritario donde las personas a
veces no tienen las posibilidades de
irse de vacaciones porque falta dinero
cuál es la programación de verano que
tiene el aceite fértil y tiene relación
justamente con el barrio en el que se
encuentra instalada al aire mercola
juega maeztu las 7 fracción diría que la
programación del aceite fértil este
verano sobre todo emana de la realidad
de los habitantes del barrio en que nos
encontramos porque la mayoría de estos
habitantes están en vacaciones sobre
todo los jóvenes con su familia no
tienen la posibilidad generalmente por
razones económicas o financieras de
partir y dejar sus casas entonces esas
familias se quedan en el departamento de
las en sangin ya nosotros junto a los
casales del barrio y los servicios
sociales de la ciudad averiguamos sus
necesidades su realidad para construir
una programación a su imagen esto quiere
decir concretamente que este verano
encontramos en aceite fértil deportes
como voleibol de playa tanca fútbol
patines o bádminton cada tarde de
miércoles a domingo pero además nuestra
programación tiene un lado lógico de
base de juegos de parque de aventuras
con una red suspendida una cabaña en los
árboles y también estamos construyendo
un indio y al final para terminar daría
un tercer ejemplo de hacer con él por
los habitantes que es un horno a pan del
barrio que estamos construyendo junto a
los vecinos de forja locos ahora muchas
gracias de la flora que las gracias y
así llegamos al final de este capítulo
de france enfocó muchas gracias por su
compañía y hasta una próxima por las
pantallas de profético 24 puntos
[Música]